[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
at some point simultaneously one of our
officers is in the area
she produces a handgun
and begins firing a woman is arrested
after opening fire at a dallas airport
and he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs for the first
time since testifying kate moss breaks
her silence plus it's potito versus
laundry the parents of the ill-fated
couple go head-to-head in recently filed
court documents and later would that
wound a in in
and of itself be fatal yes
parents of victims have an emotional
response in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckman a woman is
shot and taken into custody after she
opens fire at dallas law field airport
in texas
it happened monday morning when police
say 37 year old porsche odofoa began
firing a gun toward the ceiling an
officer on scene responded and shot her
in the leg she was taken into custody
and treated at a nearby hospital in the
days following the incident more
information about adofula's past has
come to light including a lengthy
criminal record and past outlandish
claims records obtained by the dallas
morning news show odefuwa was found
burning a house in 2019 where she
claimed to be god's prophet on multiple
occasions told police officers her home
address was singer chris brown's she
also called chris brown her husband in
multiple cases odafawa was found
incompetent to stand trial and was
referred to inpatient and outpatient
mental health services last year a
dallas county judge ruled she was not a
danger to others at a press conference
on monday the dallas police chief
explained what led up to the shooting
and how unseen officers responded
at about 10 59 a 37 year old woman gets
dropped off goes inside near the ticket
counters in front of southwest
goes at one point into a restroom
exits the restroom
now she's either put up some sort of
hoodie on or some other different type
of clothing that she actually walked in
at some point
simultaneously one of our officers is in
the area
she produces a handgun
and begins firing
at this point we don't know where
exactly the individual was aiming her
most of what we're seeing now she was
aiming uh at the ceiling
at but there was uh
several rounds that are found
simultaneously as she's doing that our
officer engages the suspect strikes her
in the lower extremities she's taken
into custody and is currently at
parkland hospital
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and co-host terry
austin taylor is the question everyone
is likely thinking so we'll ask it first
how many things had to go wrong for her
to get a gun
well brian this is basically a failure
of epic proportions with the blame
spread out all across the criminal
justice system and into the gun sellers
industry first uh how many times does
the woman have to a be violent and b
actually brandish a weapon before the
criminal justice system is going to step
up and do something um i read just last
april she brandished a gun at a hotel
clerk somewhere so this was this was in
the making uh for many years and yet
consistently the criminal justice system
essentially you know chewed her up and
spit her out how how is she able to get
her hands on a gun when there are
numerous rulings in numerous court cases
that she can't she's not even fit to
stand trial she's not competent to stand
trial how can you possibly be competent
to own a handgun this is just an epic
failure across the board yeah kind of to
use taylor's language kind of chew her
out and spit her out as a system taylor
terry the question now becomes sean the
legend brought in a life she was as
taylor said unfit to stand trial before
what's likely going to happen to her now
going forward
well look under the texas code of
criminal procedure you have to be
competent to stand trial that means you
have to understand the proceeding
against you and you have to be able to
assist your counsel i think here like
before she will not be found to be
competent and if she's not what happens
next is there are different categories
depending on the crime she could
literally be released on her own
recognizance or put bail
obviously we are hoping that that's not
going to happen but she could be put in
an outpatient restoration she could be
put in a mental hospital or if it's a
crime that's harsh enough high enough
she could be in a jail based competency
program so here i think they're going to
find her not competent and i think that
she'll be in some sort of mental health
program for sure yeah i wouldn't see any
attempted murder charges if they're
saying she's shot straight in the air
maybe reckless endangerment charges like
that could have some bail set on her
well heading north to illinois a viral
tick tocker is dead in an apparent
murder suicide law and crime
correspondent sierra gillespie has the
story
a murder-suicide rocks the windy city
when a man kills his ex-wife after she
discusses their divorce on tick-tock
girl don't do it it's not worth it
officials say 29 year old sonja khan was
shot and killed on july 18 by her
ex-husband 36 year old raheel ahmed
investigators say ahmed drove 11 hours
from his home in georgia to khan's
chicago condo as first responders
approached the scene investigators say
ahmed turned the gun on himself in a
statement to lawn crime network chicago
police said both were discovered
unresponsive with gunshot wounds to the
head this comes after a series of tick
tocks posted by khan went semi viral as
she opened up about her relationship and
divorce in one tick talk khan wrote
quote going through a divorce as a south
asian woman feels like you failed at
life sometimes the way the community
labels you the lack of emotional support
you receive and the pressure to stay
with someone because what people say is
isolating it makes it harder for women
to leave marriages that they shouldn't
have been in to begin with other videos
show khan providing support saying quote
you are not a failure because your
marriage did not work out more tick
tocks depict khan's seemingly enjoying
the single life police in georgia say
ahmed's family reported him missing
saying he was depressed and likely went
to salvage the marriage friends of khan
say the divorce was finalized back in
may officials say khan was pronounced
dead at the scene while ahmed was
pronounced dead at northwestern hospital
a weapon was recovered at the scene and
the incident is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
network i'm sierra gillespie
and in new york a man who was the sixth
co-defendant in the central park five
rape case is exonerated of the crime he
pled guilty to more than three decades
ago
in 1989 a group of black and hispanic
teens were accused of beating and raping
a white woman tricia milley while she
was out jogging in central park she
survived a brutal attack and testified
against the defendants but did not
remember the assault five teenagers went
to trial after giving false confessions
the high profile case dubbed them the
title of the central park five a sixth
member of the group stephen lopez pled
guilty in a separate case to avoid the
rape charge and avoid going to trial
decades later another man mattias reyes
who was not previously convicted of the
crime confessed to being the sole
attacker the five men's convictions were
overturned and they each received a
settlement from the city on monday
afternoon the manhattan d.a moved to
overturn lopez's conviction as well
citing flawed investigative techniques
and lopez pleading guilty in the face of
external pressure and false statements
there was also no physical evidence
which tied lopez to the attack lopez
previously spent almost four years in
prison years ago for the crime
still ahead on law and crime daily the
parents of gabby petito and brian
laundry face off in a legal battle but
first kate moss speaks out for the first
time since testifying in the deaf heard
defamation suit
[Music]
welcome back for the first time since
testifying super model kate moss breaks
her silence about the johnny depp amber
her defamation trial last month a jury
ruled largely in favor of depp saying
the actor was defamed in a washington
post op-ed written by ex-wife amber
heard heard claimed she was a survivor
of domestic abuse while debt maintained
he never physically abused her after
weeks of testimony and nearly 13 hours
of deliberations a jury awarded depth 10
million dollars in compensatory and 5
million dollars in punitive damages
heard was awarded 2 million dollars in
compensatory damages and zero in
punitive damages over statements made by
depp's attorney heard has since appealed
the ruling endeavor counter-appealed in
a newly released radio interview with
bbc four moss commented on the case
saying quote i know the truth about
johnny i know he never kicked me down
the stairs i had to say the truth moss
who had a romantic relationship with
johnny depp from 1994 to 1998 became a
cornerstone of conversation after amber
heard mentioned her while testifying
hurt alluded to an alleged kate moss
stairway incident in which she believed
moss was abused at the hands of depp
death team later called moss herself to
testify as a rebuttal witness there had
been a rainstorm
and
as i left the room i slid down the
stairs
and i hurt my back
how did you
i apologize miss moss please continue
and i screamed because i was in
because i didn't know what happened to
me and i was in pain and um
he came
running back to help me and carried me
to my room and got me medical attention
did mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or
threw me down any stairs
terry does ma speaking about her
relationship bring anything new to the
depp heard saga
not in my opinion brian look her
testimony was fortunate it was only
because on the stand amber heard
accidentally said oh yes kate mott said
that he pushed me downstairs so they
were lucky to get that in that was
evidence that was character evidence
that wouldn't normally get in it's more
prejudicial than probative but i think
the reason she did that interview if you
recall during the trial they wanted to
ask her
why did you come to testify you've never
testified before and the defense herd's
team basically said uh objection and the
judge didn't allow it so i think kate
moss just wanted to say johnny depp's a
good guy he would never do anything like
that just to support what she originally
said yeah which makes sense because the
case isn't technically over at taylor
herod and depp are both appealing the
case will moss's continued support of
death affect either appeals
you know the only thing i could say
about it on a legal uh from a legal
vantage point is this if herds attorneys
thought there was any wiggle room here
if there was any latitude anywhere
they're going to make you know make any
issue of the moss angle this shuts it
down completely this is kate moss
speaking you know through the public
letting amber heard her attorneys know i
am not and will not ever be on your side
in this back off leave me alone i'm done
yeah i'm doubting that there's going to
be any subpoenas from amber herdside to
kate moss anytime soon in this appeal
well
british socialite and former jeffrey
epstein madame gillane maxwell is moved
to a low security prison in northern
florida following her conviction for sex
trafficking maxwell was convicted in
december on five federal charges
including sex trafficking accused of
conspiring with epstein to recruit groom
and sexually abuse minors for a decade
in the late 90s and early 2000s the 60
year old was sentenced to 20 years in
prison and has since filed notice that
she intends to appeal her conviction and
sentence epstein was indicted on similar
charges in july of 2019 but died by
apparent suicide in prison a month later
despite requesting to be placed at a
prison in connecticut on friday maxwell
was moved to the tallahassee federal
correctional institution where she will
serve out the rest of her sentence
maxwell is due to be released in 2037
coming up on law and crime daily the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial plus the parents of brian laundry
respond to harsh accusations brought on
by the parents of gabby petito
[Music]
welcome back to parents of brian longer
responding to accusations that they knew
about gabby petito's death before she
was found this comes amid the late
vlogger's parents suing the laundries
for emotional distress patina was
reported missing last fall while on a
cross-country road trip with fiance
bryan laundry her body was later found
in grand teton national park her cause
of death was ruled to be strangulation
after a weeks-long manhunt laundry's
remains were discovered in a florida
reserve authorities determined he died
by suicide along with his remains
investigators found a written confession
where laundry admitted to killing potito
in recently filed court documents chris
and roberto laundry deny all allegations
in joseph petitto and nicole schmidt's
lawsuit alleging they knew their son
killed gabby and kept her slaying a
secret on monday gabby's parents
responded denying all affirmative
defenses in the laundry's filings
attempting to negate liability trial
proceedings in the case are set to begin
next august
terry in the laundry's reply they can
admit deny or neither what do they deny
that makes you believe this is going to
be a contentious case
well the laundries are basically denying
that they knew anything about gabby's
death that's the most contentious point
and if you look at the timeline i think
that it's going to be hard to refute it
although there's not going to be any
forensic evidence or we haven't heard
that there's going to be any forensic
evidence remember brian laundry returned
from that camping trip on september 1st
and between the time he returned and
when they found her body weeks later
they went on a camping trip together as
a family and they spent time together so
it's really an assumption i think that
the petito family is making that of
course brian talked to his parents he
was together with his parents they went
camping together and so of course he
must have mentioned it but they're going
to have to prove that with some sort of
evidence like phone records and i don't
think they'll be able to do that i think
probably this was all conversations and
no one has really documented that and i
don't think we're going to see that yeah
it comes back to the age-old saying it's
not what you know but what you can prove
taylor but this is an interesting part
though the laundries are arguing there
was no intent or malice could that mean
that they could have known where their
son was but just didn't mean for it to
harm the petito family and is that a
defense
so you know it's standard practice when
you're answering any type of civil
lawsuit to essentially deny every single
allegation against you except for the
ones that are so obvious such as you
know i live in new york city and my name
is taylor cost other than that you're
going to deny everything what's
interesting here is as you stated they
argue in the alternative we had no
knowledge but if we did have knowledge
it was out with that without any intent
or malice uh my position on this is
pretty basic is if
if they are able to establish that they
did have knowledge then i think the
malice and the intent is going to be
easily inferred because the whole
country was watching these parents
suffer without knowing what happened to
their daughter where's the argument that
they'll be able to make that yes we knew
but there was no intent to hurt them or
injure them their hurt and their pain
was on display for everyone to see yeah
we'll see how that plays out it's going
to be an interesting lawsuit played out
in the public as much of this case has
been so far but when we come back the
parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial parents get emotional as the
medical examiner testifies
[Music]
welcome back the man who sold the
parkland school shooter the murder
weapon takes the stand as the penalty
phase trial stretches into week two a
broward county jury will decide whether
the shooter receives a life in prison
sentence or the death penalty last year
the shooter pled guilty to 17 counts of
murder and 17 more counts of attempted
murder in connection to the deadly
shooting at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in 2018. on tuesday jurors
heard from the man who sold the gunman
his weapon
you have any procedures you follow every
customer is engaged in in conversation
we look for any
red flags any signs of why the sale
should not happen
if for any reason
anyone was uncomfortable
with anything about the sale the sale
did not happen period okay
and did you
engage that conversation with nicholas
cruz i had a brief conversation i
believe on pickup as i stated in my
deposition
i came out and asked him
what are you going to do with the rifle
and the reply was
i go shooting with my friends on the
weekends i just want my own stuff
later parents in the gallery got
emotional as the medical examiner
describes fatal wounds
gunshot wound a is a penetrating gunshot
wound to the right side of the chest
it injures the upper lobe of the right
lung
and the spinal cord is transected
there's 600 milliliters of blood in the
right side of the chest
and the seventh thoraxic vertebrae is
also fractured
okay
uh would that wound a in in in and of
itself be fatal yes
and would uh mr
alex chapter be able to
move and because he said it tran
transected his spine
it transacts his spinal cord okay at the
level of the seventh thoracic vertebrae
and what does that mean so he can't move
from that level down
taylor the devastation that this weapon
can do on a person's body will be on
full display in this trial and even the
the sale of the weapon which seems like
almost like a rubber stamp of a
conversation do you think that will
affect the broader conversation as to
whether these guns should be available
to the public
you know brian every time uh we suffer
through one of these mass casualty
events in this country i i say to myself
and i know many others say this is it
we've reached the breaking point we've
reached the tipping point you know we
can't possibly as a nation continue to
embrace assault weapons and and guns in
general and yet every single time um the
country does and we just move on until
the next one and then everybody is
shocked and upset and dismayed again and
so while this particular incident was so
devastating and so disgusting on so many
different levels i fear that it's not
going to change the broader conversation
because the strength of the gun lobby
and the gun enthusiasts in this country
is simply overwhelming and it upsets me
on a daily basis yeah i share similar
sentiments as well and we see children
dying that it doesn't move the needle
anyway well terry the man who sold the
gun to the shooter said he asked why the
defendant wanted the gun
was that enough
no absolutely not it was not enough and
these red flat logs only going to work
if you ask the right question the
witness michael morrison said he asked
whether or not what he wanted the gun
for and of course you're going to get
someone who's going to say well i just
want it for a shooting practice he's not
going to admit he wants to shoot up a
school and so even if we have some laws
in effect like a red flag law it's not
going to work unless you pursue the
individual and ask real questions
absolutely well thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you